on a quiet country road in berkshire
police are responding to reports and
armed gang
have stolen a quad bike and are towing
it away
as they come face to face with the
suspect's vehicle
one of the two officers inside the
patrol car
is pc andrew harper answering a routine
call
unaware of the tragedy that lies ahead
as one of the suspects makes a run for
it and their car tries to push past the
police vehicle
pc harper can be seen briefly on the
rear-facing camera
running towards the car a split second
later
it takes off dragging the young officer
behind it
his colleague desperately tries to catch
up
three four my colleague pc harper got
out the vehicle
i ran after the vehicle i've now lost
him
pc harper was dragged along the road at
high speed for a mile
suffering catastrophic and fatal
injuries
his personal equipment was left
scattered along the road
then further on his colleagues his
friends
were faced with the most harrowing scene
there's a body in the road
now the driver of that car 19 year old
henry long
and his two passengers albert bowers and
jesse cole
have been convicted of the manslaughter
of pc harper
the officer's widow speaking for the
first time since his death
couldn't hide her sense of anger and
injustice
that the teenagers were not found guilty
of murder
i am for the second time in a space of
one year
utterly shocked and called
the decisions made in these courts by
strangers
will never change the outcome that had
already come to us
i now have my own life sentence to bear
and believe me when i say it will be a
much more painful
soul-destroying and treacherous journey
than anyone facing a meager number of
years in prison will experience
myself and our families will spend the
rest of our days missing him
loving him and being utterly proud of
the incredible man
that he was within minutes of pc
harper's death
last august a police helicopter spotted
the suspect's car
in a nearby traveler's site
yeah i think the seats on the side of
four houses i've gotta sit i think
very very hot police body worn camera
recorded the moment
officers arrested henry long and albert
bowers
i'm arresting both of you on suspicion
of murder
all right and that's of a thames valley
police officer so suspicion of murder
with them
police officer does it look like i've
done a murder
pc harper's killers had been caught on
cctv
driving around in the hours before they
stole the quad bike
the owner's 999 call played to the court
tim fanny please watch emergency i've
got four masked men outside my house and
they've got weapons
oh and they're stealing my squad bike
i'm going out there now no no don't go
out there i'm going out there
no because they've got weapons by all
accounts
andrew harper was an extremely popular
and dedicated officer
he'd been married just four weeks before
the tragic events
that ended his life no officer
expects to die on duty but they know the
risks are ever present
mark white sky news